The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Now,
to start out today
we're going to finish up
what we did last time.
Which has to do with
partial fractions.
I told you how to
do partial fractions
in several special
cases and everybody
was trying to figure out
what the general picture was.
But I'd like to lay that out.
I'll still only do
it for an example.
But it will be somehow
a bigger example
so that you can see what
the general pattern is.
Partial fractions, remember,
is a method for breaking up
so-called rational functions.
Which are ratios of polynomials.
And it shows you that you
can always integrate them.
That's really the theme here.
And this is what's reassuring
is that it always works.
That's really the bottom line.
And that's good
because there are
a lot of integrals that don't
have formulas and these do.
It always works.
But, maybe with lots of help.
So maybe slowly.
Now, there's a little
bit of bad news,
and I have to be totally
honest and tell you
what all the bad news is.
Along with the good news.
The first step, which maybe
I should be calling Step 0,
I had a Step 1, 2 and 3
last time, is long division.
That's the step where you
take your polynomial divided
by your other polynomial,
and you find the quotient
plus some remainder.
And you do that
by long division.
And the quotient is easy
to take the antiderivative
of because it's
just a polynomial.
And the key extra
property here is
that the degree of the numerator
now over here, this remainder,
is strictly less than the
degree of the denominator.
So that you can
do the next step.
Now, the next step which I
called Step 1 last time, that's
great imagination, it's
right after Step 0, Step 1
was to factor the denominator.
And I'm going to illustrate by
example what the setup is here.
I don't know maybe,
we'll do this.
Some polynomial here,
maybe cube this one.
So here I've factored
the denominator.
That's what I called
Step 1 last time.
Now, here's the first
piece of bad news.
In reality, if somebody
gave you a multiplied
out degree-whatever
polynomial here,
you would be very hard
pressed to factor it.
A lot of them are extremely
difficult to factor.
And so that's something you
would have to give to a machine
to do.
And it's just basically
a hard problem.
So obviously, we're only
going to give you ones
that you can do by hand.
So very low degree examples.
And that's just the way it is.
So this is really a hard step
in disguise, in real life.
Anyway, we're just going
to take it as given.
And we have this
numerator, which
is of degree less
than the denominator.
So let's count up what
its degree has to be.
This is 4 + 2 + 6.
So this is degree 4 + 2 + 6.
I added that up because
this is degree 4,
this is degree 2 and
(x^2)^3 is the 6th power.
So all together it's
this, which is 12.
And so this thing
is of degree <= 11.
All the way up to
degree 11, that's
the possibilities for
the numerator here.
Now, the extra information that
I want to impart right now,
is just this setup.
Which I called Step 2 last time.
And the setup is this.
Now, it's going to take
us a while to do this.
We have this factor here.
We have another factor.
We have another term,
with the square.
We have another
term with the cube.
We have another term
with the fourth power.
So this is what's going
to happen whenever
you have linear factors.
You'll have a collection
of terms like this.
So you have four
constants to take care of.
Now, with a quadratic
in the denominator,
you need a linear
function in the numerator.
So that's, if you like,
B_0 x + C_0 divided
by this quadratic term here.
And what I didn't
show you last time
was how you deal with higher
powers of quadratic terms.
So when you have a quadratic
term, what's going to happen
is you're going to take
that first factor here.
Just the way you
did in this case.
But then you're going to
have to do the same thing
with the next power.
Now notice, just as in
the case of this top row,
I have just a constant here.
And even though I increased
the degree of the denominator
I'm not increasing
the numerator.
It's staying just a constant.
It's not linear up here.
It's better than that.
It's just a constant.
And here it stayed a constant.
Similarly here, even
though I'm increasing
the degree of the
denominator, I'm
leaving the numerator, the
form of the numerator, alone.
It's just a linear factor
and a linear factor.
So that's the key
to this pattern.
I don't have quite as
jazzy a song on mine.
So this is so long that it
runs off the blackboard here.
So let's continue
it on the next.
We've got this B_2
x + C_2-- sorry,
(B_3 x + C_3) / (x^2 + 4)^3.
I guess I have room
for it over here.
I'm going to talk about
this in just a second.
Alright, so here's the pattern.
Now, let me just do a count
of the number of unknowns
we have here.
The number of unknowns
that we have here
is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
That 12 is no coincidence.
That's the degree
of the polynomial.
And it's the number of
unknowns that we have.
And it's the number
of degrees of freedom
in a polynomial of degree 11.
If you have all these
free coefficients here,
you have the coefficient x^0,
x^1, all the way up to x^ 11.
And 0 through 11 is 12
different coefficients.
And so this is a very
complicated system
of equations for unknowns.
This is twelve equations
for twelve unknowns.
So I'll get rid of
this for a second.
So we have twelve
equations, twelve unknowns.
So that's the other bad news.
Machines handle this very
well, but human beings
have a little trouble with 12.
Now, the cover-up
method works very neatly
and picks out this term here.
But that's it.
So it reduces it to an 11 by 11.
You'll be able to
evaluate this in no time.
But that's it.
That's the only simplification
of your previous method.
We don't have a method for this.
So I'm just showing what
the whole method looks
like but really you'd
have to have a machine
to implement this once it
gets to be any size at all.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's
one big equation,
but it's a polynomial equation.
So there's an equation, there's
this function R(x) = a_11 x^11
+ a_10 x^10...
and these things are known.
This is a known expression here.
And then when you cross-multiply
on the other side,
what you have is,
well, it's A_1 times--
If you cancel this
denominator with that,
you're going to get (x + (x+2)^3
(x^2+2x+3) (x^2+4)^3 plus
the term for A_2, etc.
It's a monster equation.
And then to separate it out
into separate equations,
you take the coefficient
on x^11, x^10, ...
all the way down to x^0.
And all told, that means there
are a total of 12 equations.
11 through 0 is 12 equations.
Yeah, another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Should I
write down rest of this?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Should you
write down all this stuff?
Well, that's a good question.
So you notice I
didn't write it down.
Why didn't I write it down?
Because it's incredibly long.
In fact, you probably-- So
how many pages of writing
would this take?
This is about a page of writing.
So just think of you're
a machine, how much time
you want to spend on this.
So the answer is that
you have to be realistic.
You're a human
being, not a machine.
And so there's certain things
that you can write down
and other things you should
not attempt to write down.
So do not do this at home.
So that's the first
down-side to this method.
It gets more and more
complicated as time goes on.
The second down-side, I
want to point out to you,
is what's happening
with the pieces.
So the pieces still
need to be integrated.
We simplified this problem,
but we didn't get rid of it.
We still have the problem
of integrating the pieces.
Now, some of the
pieces are very easy.
This top row here, the
antiderivatives of these,
you can just write down.
By advanced guessing.
I'm going to skip over to the
most complicated one over here.
For one second here.
And what is it that you'd have
to deal with for that one.
You'd have to deal
with, for example,
so e.g., for example, I
need to deal with this guy.
I've got to get this
antiderivative here.
Now, this one you're
supposed to be able to know.
So this is why I'm
mentioning this.
Because this kind of
ingredient is something
you already covered.
And what is it?
Well, you do this one
by advanced guessing,
although you learned it as
the method of substitution.
You realize that it's going to
be of the form (x^2 + 4)^(-2),
roughly speaking.
And now we're going to fix that.
Because if you differentiate
it you get 2x times the -2,
that's -4 times x times this.
There's an x in
the numerator here.
So it's -1/4 of that
will fix the factor.
And here's the
answer for that one.
So that's one you can do.
The second piece is this guy.
This is the other piece.
Now, this was the piece
that came from B_3.
This is the one
And this is the one
that's coming from C_3.
This is coming from C_3.
We still need to get
this one out there.
So C_3 times that will
be the correct answer,
once we've found these numbers.
So how do we do this?
How's this one integrated?
STUDENT: Trig substitution?
PROFESSOR: Trig substitution.
So the trig substitution
here is x = 2 tan u.
Or 2 tan theta.
And when you do that, there are
a couple of simplifications.
Well, I wouldn't call
this a simplification.
This is just the differentiation
formula. dx = 2 sec^2 u du.
And then you have to plug in,
and you're using the fact that
when you plug in the
tan^2, 4 tan ^2 + 4,
you'll get a secant squared.
So altogether, this
thing is, 2 sec^2 u du.
And then there's a (4 sec^2
u)^3, in the denominator.
So that's what happens when
you change variables here.
And now look, this
keeps on going.
This is not the
end of the problem.
Because what does
that simplify to?
That is, let's see, it's
2/64, the integral of sec^6
and sec^2.
That's the same as cos^4.
And now, you did a
trig substitution
but you still have
a trig integral.
The trig integral now,
there's a method for this.
The method for this is
when it's an even power,
you have to use the
double angle formula.
So that's this guy here.
And you're still not done.
You have to square
this thing out.
And then you'll still
get a cos^2 (2u).
And it keeps on going.
So this thing goes
on for a long time.
But I'm not even
going to finish this,
but I just want to show you.
The point is, we're
not showing you how
to do any complicated problem.
We're just showing you all
the little ingredients.
And you have to
string them together
a long, long, long process to
get to the final answer of one
of these questions.
So it always works,
but maybe slowly.
By the way, there's even another
horrible thing that happens.
Which is, if you handle this
guy here, what's the technique.
This is another technique
that you learned,
supposedly within
the last few days.
Completing the square.
So this, it turns out, you
have to rewrite it this way.
And then the evaluation is going
to be expressed in terms of,
I'm going to jump to the end.
It's going to turn out to be
expressed in terms of this.
That's what will eventually
show up in the formula.
And not only that,
but if you deal
with ones involving
x as well, you'll
also need to deal with something
like log of this denominator
here.
So all of these things
will be involved.
So now, the last message that
I have for you is just this.
This thing is very complicated.
We're certainly never
going to ask you to do it.
But you should just be aware
that this level of complexity,
we are absolutely stuck
with in this problem.
And the reason why
we're stuck with it
is that this is what the
formulas look like in the end.
If the answers look
like this, the formulas
have to be this complicated.
If you differentiate this,
you get your polynomial,
your ratio of polynomials.
If you differentiate this, you
get some ratio of polynomials.
These are the
things that come up
when you take antiderivatives
of those rational functions.
So we're just stuck
with these guys.
And so don't let it
get to you too much.
I mean, it's not so bad.
In fact, there are
computer programs
that will do this for
you anytime you want.
And you just have to be
not intimidated by them.
They're like other functions.
OK, that's it for the general
comments on partial fractions.
Now we're going to change
subjects to our last technique.
This is one more
technical thing to get
you familiar with functions.
And this technique is
called integration by parts.
Please, just because
its name sort
of sounds like
partial fractions,
don't think it's the same thing.
It's totally different.
It's not the same.
So this one is called
integration by parts.
Now, unlike the previous case,
where I couldn't actually
justify to you that the
linear algebra always works.
I claimed it worked, but
I wasn't able to prove it.
That's a complicated
theorem which I'm not
able to do in this class.
Here I can explain to
you what's going on
with integration by parts.
It's just the fundamental
theorem of calculus,
if you like, coupled
with the product formula.
Sort of unwound and
read in reverse.
And here's how that works.
If you take the product of two
functions and you differentiate
them, then we know that the
product rule says that this is
u'v + uv'.
And now I'm just going to
rearrange in the following way.
I'm going to solve for uv'.
That is, this term here.
So what is this term?
It's this other term, (uv)'.
Minus the other piece.
So I just rewrote this equation.
And now I'm going
to integrate it.
So here's the formula.
The integral of
the left-hand side
is equal to the integral
of the right-hand side.
Well when I integrate
a derivative,
of I get back the
function itself.
That's the fundamental theorem.
So this is it.
Sorry, I missed the
dx, which is important.
I apologize.
Let's put that in there.
So this is the integration
by parts formula.
I'm going to write it one more
time with the limits stuck in.
It's also written this way, when
you have a definite integral.
Just the same formula,
written twice.
Alright, now I'm
going to show you
how it works on a few examples.
And I have to give you a
flavor for how it works.
But it'll grow as we get
more and more experience.
The first example
that I'm going to take
is one that looks intractable
on the face of it.
Which is the
integral of ln x dx.
Now, it looks like there's sort
of nothing we can do with this.
And we don't know
what the solution is.
However, I claim that if
we fit it into this form,
we can figure out what the
integral is relatively easily.
By some little magic of
cancellation, it happens.
The idea is the following.
If I consider this
function to be u,
then what's going to
appear on the other side
in the integrated form
is the function u', which
is-- so, if you like, u = ln x.
So u' = 1 / x.
Now, 1 / x is a more
manageable function than ln x.
What we're using is that when
we differentiate the function,
it's getting nicer.
It's getting more
tractable for us.
In order for this to
fit into this pattern,
however, I need a function
v. So what in the world
am I going to put here for v?
The answer is, well, dx is
almost the right answer.
The answer turns out to be x.
And the reason is that
that makes v' = 1.
It makes v' = 1.
So that means that this
is u, but it's also uv'.
Which was what I had
on the left-hand side.
So it's both u and uv'.
So this is the setup.
And now all I'm going to do is
read off what the formula says.
What it says is, this is
equal to u times v. So u
is this and v is that.
So it's x ln x minus, so
that again, this is uv.
Except in the other order, vu.
And then I'm integrating, and
what do I have to integrate?
u'v. So look up there.
u'v with a minus sign here.
u' = 1 / x, and v = x.
So it's 1 / x, that's u'.
And here is x, that's v, dx.
Now, that one is
easy to integrate.
Because (1/x) x = 1.
And the integral of 1 dx
is x, plus c, if you like.
So the antiderivative of 1 is x.
And so here's our answer.
Our answer is that
this is x ln x - x + c.
I'm going to do two
more slightly more
complicated examples.
And then really,
the main thing is
to get yourself
used to this method.
And there's no one
way of doing that.
Just practice makes perfect.
And so we'll just do
a few more examples.
And illustrate them.
The second example that I'm
going to use is the integral
of (ln x)^2 dx.
And this is just slightly
more recalcitrant.
Namely, I'm going to
let u be (ln x)^2.
And again, v = x.
So that matches up here.
That is, v' = 1.
So this is uv'.
So this thing is uv'.
And then we'll just
see what happens.
Now, the game that we get
is that when I differentiate
the logarithm squared, I'm going
to to get something simpler.
It's not going to win
us the whole battle,
but it will get us started.
So here we get u'.
And that's 2 ln x times 1/x.
Applying the chain rule.
And so the formula is
that this is x (ln x)^2,
minus the integral of,
well it's u'v, right,
that's what I have
to put over here.
So u' = 2 ln x 1/x and v = x.
And so now, you notice something
interesting happening here.
So let me just demarcate
this a little bit.
And let you see what it
is that I'm doing here.
So notice, this is
the same integral.
So here we have x (ln x)^2.
We've already solved that part.
But now know notice that
the 1/x and the x cancel.
So we're back to
the previous case.
We didn't win all the way, but
actually we reduced ourselves
to this integral.
To the integral of ln x,
which we already know.
So here, I can copy that down.
That's - -2(x ln x - x),
and then I have to throw
in a constant, c.
And that's the end
of the problem here.
That's it.
So this piece, I
got from Example 1.
Now, this illustrates
a principle
which is a little
bit more complicated
than just the one of
integration by parts.
Which is a sort of a
general principle which
I'll call my Example 3,
which is something which
is called a reduction formula.
A reduction formula is a
case where we apply some rule
and we figure out one
of these integrals
in terms of something else.
Which is a little bit simpler.
And eventually we'll
get down to the end,
but it may take us n
steps from the beginning.
So the example is (ln x)^n dx.
.
And the claim is that if I
do what I did in Example 2,
to this case, I'll get a
simpler one which will involve
the (n-1)st power.
And that way I can
get all the way
back down to the final answer.
So here's what happens.
We take u as (ln x)^n.
This is the same discussion
as before, v = x.
And then u' is n n
(ln x)^(n-1) 1/x.
And v' is 1.
And so the setup is similar.
We have here x (ln x)^n
minus the integral.
And there's n times, it
turns out to be (ln x)^(n-1).
And then there's a 1/x
and an x, which cancel.
So I'm going to explain
this also abstractly
a little bit just to show
you what's happening here.
If you use the notation F_n(x)
is the integral of (ln x)^n dx,
and we're going to
forget the constant here.
Then the relationship that we
have here is that F_n(x) is
equal to n ln-- I'm
sorry, x (ln x)^n.
That's the first term over here.
Minus n times the preceding one.
This one here.
And the idea is that
eventually we can get down.
If we start with the nth one, we
have a formula that includes--
So the reduction is
to the n (n-1)st.
Then we can reduce to
the (n-2)nd and so on.
Until we reduce to
the 1, the first one.
And then in fact we can
even go down to the 0th one.
So this is the idea of
a reduction formula.
And let me illustrate it exactly
in the context of Examples 1
and 2.
So the first step would be
to evaluate the first one.
Which is, if you
like, (ln x)^0 dx.
That's very easy, that's x.
And then F_1(x) =
x ln x - F_0(x).
Now, that's applying this rule.
So let me just put
it in a box here.
This is the method of induction.
Here's the rule.
And I'm applying it for n = 1.
I plugged in n = 1 here.
So here, I have x
(ln x)^1 - 1*F_0(x).
And that's what I put right
here, on the right-hand side.
And that's going to generate
for me the formula that I want,
which is x ln x - x.
That's the answer to
this problem over here.
This was Example 1.
Notice I dropped the
constants because I
can add them in at the end.
So I'll put in
parentheses here, plus c.
That's what would happen
at the end of the problem.
The next step, so that was
Example 1, and now Example 2
works more or less the same way.
I'm just summarizing what
I did on that blackboard
right up here.
The same thing, but in
much more compact notation.
If I take F_2(x), that's going
to be equal to x (ln x)^2 -
2 F_1(x).
Again, this is box for n = 2.
And if I plug it in, what I'm
getting here is x (ln x)^2
minus twice this stuff here.
Which is right here. x ln x - x.
If you like, plus c.
So I'll leave the c off.
So this is how reduction
formulas work in general.
I'm going to give you one more
example of a reduction formula.
So I guess we have to
call this Example 4.
Let's be fancy, let's
make it the sine.
No no, no, let's
be fancier still.
Let's make it e^x So this would
also work for cos x and sin x.
The same sort of thing.
And I should mention
that on your homework,
you have to do it for cos x.
I decided to change my mind
on the spur of the moment.
I'm not going to
do it for cosine
because you have to work it out
on your homework for cosine.
In a later homework
you'll even do this case.
So it's fine.
You need the practice.
OK, so how am I going
to do it this time.
This is again, a
reduction formula.
And the trick here is to pick
u to be this function here.
And the reason is the following.
So it's very important to
pick which function is the u
and which function is the v.
That's the only decision you
have to make if you're going
to apply integration by parts.
When I pick this function as
the u, the advantage that I have
is that u' is simpler.
How is it simpler?
It's simpler because
it's one degree down.
So that's making
progress for us.
On the other hand,
this function here
is going to be what
I'll use for v.
And if I differentiated that,
if I did it the other way around
and I differentiated
that, I would just get
the same level of complexity.
Differentiating e^x
just gives you back e^x.
So that's boring.
It doesn't make any
progress in this process.
And so I'm going to instead
let v = e^x and-- Sorry,
this is v'.
Make it v' = e^x.
And then v = e^x.
At least it isn't any worse
when I went backwards like that.
So now, I have u and v',
and now I get x^n e^x.
This again is u, and this is v.
So it happens that v is equal
to v ' so it's a
little confusing here.
But this is the one
we're calling v'.
And here's v. And now minus
the integral and I have here
nx^(n-1).
And I have here e^x.
So this is u' and this is v dx.
So this recurrence
is a new recurrence.
And let me summarize it here.
It's saying that G_n(x) should
be the integral of x^n e^x dx.
Again, I'm dropping the c.
And then the reduction formula
is that G_n(x) is equal to this
expression here: x^n
e^x - n*G_(n-1)(x).
So here's our reduction formula.
And to illustrate
this, if I take G_0(x),
if you think about it
for a second that's just,
there's nothing here.
The antiderivative of e^x,
that's going to be e^x,
that's getting started at
the real basement here.
Again, as always, 0
is my favorite number.
Not 1.
I always start with the
easiest one, if possible.
And now G_1, applying
this formula,
is going to be equal
to x e^x - G_0(x).
Which is just-- Right,
because n is 1 and n - 1 is 0.
And so that's just
^ x e^x - e^x.
So this is a very,
very fancy way
of saying the following fact.
I'll put it over on
this other board.
Which is that the integral of
x e^x dx is equal to x e^x -
x + c.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question
is, why is this true.
Why is this statement true.
Why is G_0 equal to e^x.
I did that in my head.
What I did was, I first wrote
down the formula for G_0.
Which was G_0 is equal to
the integral of e^x dx.
Because there's an x to
the 0 power in there,
which is just 1.
And then I know the
antiderivative of e^x.
It's e^x.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How do you know
when this method will work?
The answer is only
by experience.
You must get
practice doing this.
If you look in your
textbook, you'll
see hints as to what to do.
The other hint
that I want to say
is that if you
find that you have
one factor in your expression
which when you differentiate
it, it gets easier.
And when you antidifferentiate
the other half,
it doesn't get any
worse, then that's
when this method has
a chance of helping.
And there is-- there's
no general thing.
The thing is, though, if you
do it with x^n e^x, x^n cos x,
x^n sin x, those are
examples where it works.
This power of the log.
I'll give you one
more example here.
So this was G_1(x), right.
I'll give you one more
example in a second.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
There's a mistake here.
That's bad.
I was thinking in the back of my
head of the following formula.
Which is another one
which we've just done.
So these are the types of
formulas that you can get out
of integration by parts.
There's also another way of
getting these, which I'm not
going to say anything about.
Which is called
advance guessing.
You guess in advance what the
form is, you differentiate it
and you check.
That does work too, with
many of these cases.
I want to give you
an illustration.
Just because, you know, these
formulas are somewhat dry.
So I want to give you just
at least one application.
We're almost done with the
idea of these formulas.
And we're going to
get back now to being
able to handle lots more
integrals than we could before.
And what's satisfying
is that now we
can get numbers out instead
of being stuck and hamstrung
with only a few techniques.
Now we have all of the
techniques of integration
that anybody has.
And so we can do
pretty much anything
we want that's possible to do.
So here's, if you like,
an application that
illustrates how integration
by parts can be helpful.
And we're going to find the
volume of an exponential wine
glass here.
Again, don't try
this at home, but.
So let's see.
It's going to be this
beautiful guy here.
I think.
OK, so what's it going to be.
This graph is going
to be y = e^x.
Then we're going to rotate
it around the y-axis.
And this level here
is the height y = 1.
And the top, let's
say, is y = e.
So that the horizontal
here, coming down, is x = 1.
Now, there are two ways
to set up this problem.
And so there are two methods.
And this is also a good
review because, of course,
we did this in the last unit.
The two methods are horizontal
and vertical slices.
Those are the two
ways we can do this.
Now, if we do it with--
So let's start out
with the horizontal ones.
That's this shape here.
And we're going like that.
And the horizontal slices
mean that this little bit here
is of thickness dy.
And then we're going
to wrap that around.
So this is going
to become a disk.
This is the method of disks.
And what's this distance here?
Well, this place is x.
And so the disk has area pi x^2.
And we're going to
add up the thickness
of the disks and we're going
to integrate from 1 to e.
So here's our volume.
And now we have one last
little item of business
before we can evaluate
this integral.
And that is that we need to
know the relationship here
on the curve, that y = e^x.
So that means x = ln y.
And in order to
evaluate this integral,
we have to evaluate x
correctly as a function of y.
So that's the integral from 1
to e of (ln y)^2, times pi, dy.
So now you see that
this is an integral
that we did calculate already.
And in fact, it's
sitting right here.
Except with the variable x
instead of the variable y.
So the answer, which we already
had, is this F_2(y) here.
So maybe I'll write it that way.
So this is F_2(y)
between 1 and e.
And now let's figure
out what it is.
It's written over there.
It's y (ln y)^2 - 2(y ln y - y).
The whole thing
evaluated at 1, e.
And that is, if I plug
in e here, I get e.
Except there's a factor
of pi there, sorry.
Missed the pi factor.
So there's an e here.
And then I subtract off,
well, at 1 this is e - e.
So it cancels.
There's nothing left.
And then at 1, I
get ln 1 is 0, ln 1
is 0, there's only one
term left, which is 2.
So it's -2.
That's the answer.
Now we get to compare
that with what happens
if we do it the other way.
So what's the vertical?
So by vertical
slicing, we get shells.
And that starts-- That's
in the x variable.
It starts at 0 and
ends at 1 and it's dx.
And what are the shells?
Well, the shells are, if I
can draw the picture again,
they start-- the top value is e.
And the bottom value is, I need
a little bit of room for this.
The bottom value is y.
And then we have 2 pi
x is the circumference,
as we sweep it around dx.
So here's our new volume.
Expressed in this different way.
So now I'm going to
plug in what this is.
It's the integral from
0 to 1 of e minus e^x,
that's the formula
for y, 2 pi x dx.
And what you see is that
you get the integral
from 0 to 1 of 2 pi e x dx.
That's easy, right?
That's just 2 pi e times 1/2.
This one is just the
area of a triangle.
If I factor out the 2 pi e.
And then the other piece is
the integral of 2 pi x e^x dx.
From 0 to 1.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] PROFESSOR:
Are you asking me whether I
need an x^2 here?
I just evaluated the integral.
I just did it geometrically.
I said, this is the
area of a triangle.
I didn't antidifferentiate
and evaluate it,
I just told you the number.
Because it's a
definite integral.
So now, this one here, I
can read off from right up
here, above it.
This is G_1.
So this is equal to,
let's check it out here.
So this is pi e, right,
minus 2 pi G_1(x),
evaluated at 0 and 1.
So let's make sure that it's
the same as what we had before.
It's pi e minus 2 pi
times-- here's G_1.
So it's x e^x - e^x.
So at x = 1, that cancels.
But at the bottom end, it's e^0.
So it's -1 here.
Is that right?
Yep.
So it's pi e - 2.
It's the same.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: From here to
here, is that the question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the step here
is just the distributive law.
This is e 2 pi x,
that's this term.
And the other terms, the
minus sign is outside.
The 2 pi I factored out.
And the x and the e^x stayed
inside the integral sign.
Thank you.
The correction is that
there was a missing minus
sign, last time.
When I integrated from 0 to 1,
x e^x dx, I had a x e^x - e^x.
Evaluated at 0 and 1.
And that's equal to +1.
I was missing this minus sign.
The place where it came in
was in this wineglass example.
We had the integral of
2 pi x (e - e^x) dx.
And that was 2 pi e integral
of x dx, from 0 to 1, -2 pi,
integral from 0
to 1 of x e^x dx.
And then I worked this
out and it was pi e.
And then this one was -2 pi,
and what I wrote down was -1.
But there should have been
an extra minus sign there.
So it's this.
The final answer was
correct, but this minus sign
was missing.
Right there.
So just, right there.